[Applause]
dawn breaking in london and the labour
mayor in good spirits
the capitals council's changing hands
labour winning here in wandsworth a
symbolic success for the party
and the outgoing conservative leader
clear national issues at play the cost
of living is a bit of an issue and
people are complaining about that there
have been other comments about what is
happening nationally which is affecting
people's judgment and people are making
that judgment between national and local
and casting their vote as they want to
partygate also spoiling the mood for
conservative councillors in westminster
another tory council fall into labour
for the first time
ever
jubilation for him
here in barnet to hug in the handover of
a third tory council this is a big
turning point for us from the depths of
2019 that general election
back on track that change this last two
years has been really hard for us as a
party but we've done it we've built
those solid foundations
solid strides and fresh foundations in
southern england perhaps more troubling
for boris johnson the liberal democrats
finally regaining ground
from the tory heartlands of west
oxfordshire to south west england in the
town of taunton i wasn't expecting that
the lib dems exceeding expectations
what began as a tremor
in cheshire
became a earthquake in north shropshire
with our victories
in westmoreland and furnace
and our victories here in somerset
it's now become a political shock wave
that could bring down this appalling
conservative government
i might go it looks a bit greener
that not the picture this pm would paint
of this set of election results by no
means the royal reception you received
at last year's elections but this not a
total catastrophe either she is the
longest serving
monarch
in the history of the country boris
johnson dismissing symbolic losses and
minor gains as mid-term blues
it's midterm and it's certainly a mixed
set of results and
we've had a tough night in some parts of
the of the country but on the other hand
in other parts of the country you're
still seeing uh conservatives going
forward and
making uh quite remarkable gains the big
lesson that i take from this is that
this is a message from voters that what
they want us to do above all one two and
three is focus on the big issues that
matter to them but just down the road
from the pm on this visit to his
constituency his own mp say partygate
very much did matter it's very clear on
doorsteps there is a message here people
have switched their votes to lots of
different other parties they haven't
endorsed labor endorse the liberal
democrats of the greens but they are
clearly sending a message to my party to
the government that i support to say
that there needs to be some change
across london the day didn't start well
for the prime minister from wandsworth
to here in westminster the tory party
losing crucial ground in london number
10 predicted it was going to be a
grizzly night but in this fast ballot
box test for the prime minister since
the party scandal broke he emerged
battered but not entirely broken holding
enough ground in the red wall to hold
off his critics for now
this man the tory's scottish leader was
for a while one of his critics now back
behind the prime minister but behind in
the polls too the scottish tour is now
in a sore third place in scotland losing
more than 60 councillors across the
country as labour moved to second place
i aspire for us to be
in first place that's a long road ahead
i'm really pleased we're demonstrating
real progress over the course of the
last year that's been borne out by these
results where we've made gains yes from
the conservatives but we've also gained
seats from the snp we've won in places
we haven't won in for a very very long
time so a good day for the scottish
labour party but i want us to drive
forward
from scotland to the south and to london
these are bad set of results for boris
johnson but they could prove the least
of his worries as a recession and
double-digit inflation looms